En 1962, con la "Primavera Silenciosa" de Rachel Carson
Pienso que para gente como yo en el mundo de hacer cosas,
el canario en la mina ya no cantaba.
Y así la pregunta de que podría no haber pájaros
se volvió casi fundamental para aquellos de nosotros que deambulábamos por los alrededores
buscando a los "meadowlarks" (loicas) que parecían haber desaparecido por completo.
Y la pregunta era, ¿estaban cantando los pájaros?
Ahora, no soy un científico, eso está claro.
Pero, saben, acabamos de tener una discusión de lo que podría ser un pájaro.
¿Qué es un pájaro?
Bueno, en mi mundo, esto es un pato de goma.
Se presenta en California con una advertencia--
"Este producto contiene químicos conocidos por el Estado de California
de ser causantes de cáncer y problemas de nacimiento u otros daños reproductivos".
Esto es un pájaro.
¿Qué clase de cultura produciría un producto de este tipo
y luego lo etiquetaría y lo vendería a los niños?
Creo que tenemos un problema de diseño.
Alguien escuchó las seis horas de charla que di
llamada "Los Diálogos de Monticello" en la Radio Pública Nacional ("National Public Radio" NPR), y me envió esto como nota de agradecimiento --
"Nos damos cuenta de que el diseño es una señal de intención,
pero también debe ocurrir dentro de un mundo,
y tenemos que entender ese mundo a fin de
impregnar nuestros diseños con inteligencia inherente,
y así, si miramos atrás al estado básico de las cosas
en el que nosotros diseñamos, nosotros, de alguna manera, necesitamos ir a la condición primordial
para entender el sistema operativo y las condiciones del marco de un planeta,
y yo pienso que la parte emocionante de eso son las buenas noticias que están allí,
porque las noticias son las noticias de abundancia,
y no las noticias de límites,
y pienso que mientras nuestra cultura se tortura a sí misma ahora
con tiranías y preocupaciones sobre los límites y el miedo,
nosotros podemos añadir esta otra dimensión de abundancia que es coherente,
movida por el sol, y empezar a imaginar
lo que sería compartir".
Fue bonito recibir eso.
Eso fue una frase.
Henry James estaría orgulloso.
Esto es -- Lo destaqué en la parte de abajo,
pero era extemporáneo, obviamente.
El tema fundamental es que, para mí,
el diseño es el primer signo de intenciones humanas.
Así que cuáles son nuestras intenciones, y cuáles van a ser nuestras intenciones --
Si nos levantamos por la mañana, tenemos diseños en el mundo --
entonces, ¿cuál será nuestra intención como especie
ahora que somos la especie dominante?
Y no es sólo un debate de dirección y dominio
porque realmente, el dominio está implícito en la dirección --
porque ¿cómo puedes dirigir algo que has matado?
Y la dirección está implícita en el dominio,
porque no puedes ser el director de algo si no puedes dominarlo.
Entonces la pregunta es, ¿cuál es la primera pregunta para los diseñadores?
Ahora como guardianes -- hablemos del estado, por ejemplo,
que se reserva el derecho de matar, el derecho de ser engañoso y así sucesivamente --
la pregunta que hacemos al guardián en este punto es
¿estamos para, cómo estamos para,
asegurar a las sociedades locales, crear la paz mundial
y salvar al medio ambiente?
Pero no sé si ése será el debate común.
El comercio, por otra parte, es relativamente rápido,
esencialmente creativo, altamente eficaz y eficiente,
y fundamentalmente honesto, porque no podemos intercambiar
valores por mucho tiempo si no confiamos los unos en los otros.
Así que usamos las heramientas del comercio, principalmente para nuestro trabajo,
pero la pregunta que traemos a colación es,
¿Cómo amamos a todos los niños de todas las especies indefinidamente?
Así que empezamos nuestros diseños con esa pregunta.
Porque nos damos cuenta de que hoy en día la cultura moderna
parece haber adoptado la estrategia de tragedia.
Si venimos aquí y decimos, "Bueno, no fue mi intención
causar el calentamiento global mientras tomaba mis decisiones"
y decimos, "Eso no es parte de mi plan",
entonces nos damos cuenta de que es parte de nuestro plan de facto.
Porque es lo que está pasando porque no tenemos ningún otro plan.
Y estuve en la Casa Blanca a petición del Presidente Bush,
reuniéndome con cada departamento y agencia federal,
y señalé que parecían no tener ningún plan.
Si el "endgame" (fin de juego) es el calentamiento global, lo están haciendo genial.
Si el "endgame" (fin de juego) es la intoxicación con mercurio de nuestros niños
a sotavento de las plantas de carbón de fuego y han derrotado la Ley de Aire Limpio
entonces veo que nuestros programas educativos deberían ser explícitamente definidos como
"Muerte cerebral para todos los niños, que ninguno se quede atrás"
(Aplausos)
Entonces, la pregunta es ¿cuántos oficiales federales
están listos para mudarse a Ohio y Pennsylvania con sus familias?
Porque si no tienen un "endgame" (fin de juego) de algo exquisito
entonces sólo están moviendo las piezas de ajedrez de un lado a otro,
si no saben que están buscando al rey.
Así que quizá podríamos desarrollar una estrategia de cambio,
que requiere humildad. Y en mi trabajo como arquitecto,
es lamentable que la palabra humildad y la palabra arquitecto
no hayan aparecido en el mismo párrafo desde "El Manantial" ("The Fountainhead")
Así que si si alguien aquí tiene algún problema con el concepto de diseño humilde,
reflexionen sobre esto -- nos tomó 5000 años
poner ruedas a nuestro equipaje.
Así, como señaló Kevin Kelly, no hay "endgame" (fin de juego).
Hay un "infinite game" (juego infinito) y nosotros jugamos en ese "infinite game" (juego infinito).
Y le hemos llamado "de cuna a cuna",
y nuestro objetivo es muy sencillo.
Esto fue lo que presenté a la Casa Blanca.
Nuestro objetivo es un mundo exquisítamente diverso, seguro, sano y justo,
con aire limpio, agua limpia, suelos y energía --
económica, equitativa, ecológica y elegantemente disfrutado, punto.
(Aplausos)
¿Qué es lo que no les gusta de esto?
¿Qué parte no les gusta?
Así que nos dimos cuenta que queríamos diversidad total,
aunque pueda ser difícil de recordar lo que dijo De Gaulle
cuando se le preguntó cómo era ser el Presidente de Francia.
Él respondió, "¿Cómo crees que es tratar de gobernar un país con 400 tipos de queso diferentes?"
Pero al mismo tiempo, nos dimos cuenta de que nuestros productos no son sanos y seguros.
Así que hemos diseñado productos
y hemos analizado los químicos hasta las partes por millón.
Esta es una manta para bebes de Pendleton que nutrirá a sus niños
en lugar de provocarle Alzheimer más adelante.
Podemos preguntarnos a nosotros mismos, ¿Qué es la justicia,
es ciega la justicia, o es la ceguera de la justicia?
¿Y en qué momento este uniforme pasó a ser de blanco a negro?
El agua ha sido declarada un derecho humano por las Naciones Unidas.
La calidad del aire es obviamente necesaria para cualquiera que respire.
¿Hay alguien aquí que no respire?
La pureza de los suelos es un problema crítico -- la nitrificación, las zonas muertas
en el Golfo de México.
Un tema fundamental que no se está tomando en cuenta.
Hemos visto la primera forma de energía solar
que venció la hegemonía de los combustibles fósiles en forma de viento
aquí en las Grandes Planicies, y así esa hegemonía se está marchando.
Y si recordamos a Sheikh Yamani cuando formó la OPEP
le preguntaron, "¿Cuándo veremos el fin de la era del petróleo?"
No sé si recuerdan su respuesta, pero fue,
"La Edad de Piedra no terminó porque nos quedamos sin piedras".
Vemos que la empresas que actúan éticamente en este mundo
están superando a aquellas que no lo hacen.
Vemos el flujo de materiales en una perspectiva bastante aterradora.
Esta es un monitora de un hospital de Los Ángeles, enviada a China.
Esta mujer se expondrá a si misma a a fósforo tóxico,
liberará cuatro libras tóxicos de plomo en el medio ambiente de sus niños,
que es del cobre.
Por otra parte, vemos grandes señales de esperanza.
Aquí está el Dr. Venkataswamy en India, que ha encontrado la manera
de llevar la salud a una escala masiva.
Ha dado visión gratuitamente a dos millones de personas.
Vemos en el flujo de nuestros materiales que el acero de los coches no vuelve a ser acero de coches
por los contaminantes de los revestimientos --
bismuto, antimonio, cobre, entre otros.
Se convierten en acero para la construcción.
Por otra parte, estamos trabajando con Berkshire Hathaway,
Warren Buffett y Moquetas Shaw,
la empresa más grande de moquetas a nivel mundial.
Hemos desarrollado una moqueta que es continuamente reciclable,
hasta las partes por millón.
La parte superior es Nailon 6 que puede volver a ser caprolactama,
La parte inferior, un poliolefino -- termoplástico infinitamente reciclable.
Ahora si yo fuera un pájaro, el edificio de mi izquierda es un déficit.
El edificio de mi derecha, que es nuestro campus corporativo para El Gap
con una antigua pradera, es un activo - su nidificación.
Aquí es de dónde yo vengo. Crecí en Hong Kong.
con seis millones de personas en 40 millas cuadradas.
Durante la estación seca, teníamos cuatro horas de agua cada cuatro días.
Y la relación con el paisaje era una de agricultores que han estado
cultivando el mismo trozo de suelo por cuarenta siglos.
No puedes cultivar el mismo trozo de suelo por cuarenta siglos
sin entender el flujo de nutrientes.
Los veranos de mi infancia fueron en el Puget Sound de Washington,
entre el crecimiento inicial y los árboles maduros.
Mi abuelo había sido leñador en los Juegos Olímpicos,
así que tengo bastante karma de árboles que estoy resolviendo.
Fui a Yale para mi posgrado,
estudié en un edificio de este estilo, de Le Corbusier,
cariñosamente conocido en nuestro negocio como Brutalismo.
Si observamos el mundo de la arquitectura,
vemos la torre de Mies en Berlín, 1928,
la pregunta podría ser, "Bueno, ¿dónde esta el sol?",
Y esto puede haber funcionado en Berlín, pero la construimos en Houston,
y las ventanas están todas cerradas. Y con la mayoría de los productos
que parecen no haber sido diseñados para ser usados en interiores,
esto es ciertamente una cámara de gas vertical.
Cuando fui a Yale, tuvimos la primera crisis energética,
y yo estaba diseñando la primera casa con calenfacción solar en Irlanda,
como estudiante, que luego construí --
que puede darles una idea de mi ambición.
Y Richard Meiers, que era uno de mis profesores,
continuaba pasando por mi escritorio para hacerme críticas,
y me dijo, "Bill, tienes que entender --
la energía solar no tiene nada que ver con la arquitectura".
Supongo que no leyó Vitruvio.
En 1984, hicimos la primera llamada "oficina verde" en América
para la Defensa Medioambiental.
Comenzamos preguntando a los fabricantes qué había en sus materiales.
Nos dijeron, "Ellos tienen los derechos de propiedad, son legales, váyanse".
El único trabajo de calidad de interiores hecho para aquel momento en este país
estaba patrocinado por la Compañía Tabacalera R.J. Reynolds,
y era para comprobar que no había ningún peligro
con el humo de segunda mano en los espacios de trabajo.
Así que, súbitamente, aquí estoy, graduándome de la escuela secundaria en 1969,
y esto sucede, y nos damos cuenta de que "fuera" desapareció.
¿Recuerdan que solemos tirar las cosas "fuera", y nos señalan "fuera"?
Y sin embargo, la NOAA (Administración Nacional Oceánica y Atmosférica) nos ha mostrado, por ejemplo --
¿Ven esa pequeña cosa azul sobre Hawaii?
Este es el Giro del Pacífico.
Allí, el plancton fue recientemente muestreado por científicos
y encontraron seis veces más plástico que plancton.
Cuando se les preguntó, dijeron, "Es como una especie de retrete gigante que no se vacía".
Quizá eso sea "fuera"
Así que estamos buscando las reglas de diseño de esto --
esta es la mayor biodiversidad de árboles en el mundo, Irian Jaya,
259 especies de árboles, y lo describimos
en el libro, "De Cuna a Cuna".
El libro es sí mismo es un polímero. No es un árbol.
Y así se titula el primer capítulo -- "Este Libro No es un Árbol".
Porque en poesía, como ha señalado Margaret Atwood,
"escribimos nuestra historia sobre la piel de los peces
con la sangre de los osos".
Y con tanto polímero, lo que realmente necesitamos
es nutrición técnica, y utilizar algo
tan elegante como un árbol -- imagínense este encargo de diseño:
Diseñar algo que haga oxígeno, secuestre el carbono,
fije el nitrógeno, destile agua, acumule la energía solar como combustible,
produzca azúcares complejas y comida, cree microclimas,
cambie los colores con las estaciones y se auto-replique.
Bueno, ¿por qué no lo derribamos y escribimos sobre él?
(Risas)
Así que buscamos el mismo criterio
que la mayoría de las personas -- saben, ¿puedo costearlo?
¿Funciona? ¿Me gusta?
Estamos añadiendo el programa jeffersoniano, ya que yo vengo de Charlottesville,
dónde he tenido el privilegio de vivir en una casa diseñada por Thomas Jefferson.
Estamos añadiendo vida, libertad y la búsqueda de la felicidad.
Ahora si observamos la palabra competición,
Estoy seguro de que la mayoría de ustedes la habrán utilizado.
Saben, la mayoría de la gente no se da cuenta de que viene del
Latín "competare", que significa esforzarse juntos.
Se refiere a la forma en la que los atletas olímpicos se entrenaban unos con otros.
Se ponían en forma juntos, y luego competían.
Las hermanas Williams compiten -- uno gana el Wimbledon.
Así que hemos estado mirando la idea de competición
como una manera de cooperar con el fin de ponernos en forma juntos.
Y el gobierno chino tiene ahora --
Yo trabajo con el gobierno chino en este momento --
ha tomado esta idea.
Estamos buscando también la supervivencia del más apto,
no sólo en términos de competición en nuestro contexto moderno
de destruir al otro o golpearlo hasta que se rinda,
sino realmente encajar y especializarnos
y gozar del desarrollo, lo que es bueno.
Ahora la mayoría de los ambientalistas no dicen que el crecimiento sea bueno,
porque, en nuestro léxico, "asfalto" son dos palabras imputando culpa. ('as fault' = en falta)
Pero si vemos al asfalto como nuestro desarrollo,
entonces nos damos cuenta de que lo que estamos haciendo es destruyendo
el subyacente sistema operativo fundamental del planeta.
Entonces cuando vemos que E es igual a mc al cuadrado, desde una perspectiva poética,
vemos energía como física, química como masa,
y repentinamente, obtienen esta biología.
Y tenemos mucha energía, así que resolveremos ese problema,
pero el problema de la biología es engañoso, porque al someter a la tierra
a todos estos materiales tóxicos que arrojamos en ella,
no seremos nunca capaces de recuperar eso.
Y como Francis Crick ha señalado, nueve años
después de descubrir el ADN con el Sr. Watson,
la vida en sí misma debe tener crecimiento como condición previa --
debe tener energía gratuita, luz solar
y necesita ser un sistema químicamente abiert de químicos.
Así que estamos buscando que el artificio humano se convierta en una cosa viva,
y queremos crecimiento, queremos energía gratuita de la luz solar
y queremos un metabolismo abierto para los productos químicos.
Entonces, la pregunta cambia de 'crecimiento o no crecimiento',
a ¿qué quieren hacer crecer?
Así que en lugar de hacer crecer destrucción,
queremos hacer crecer cosas que podamos disfrutar,
y algún día la FDA (Administración de Drogas y Alimentos) nos permitirá hacer queso francés.
Por tanto, tenemos estos dos metabolismos,
y yo trabajé con un químico alemán, Michael Braungart,
y hemos identificado los dos metabolismos fundamentales.
El biológico, que estoy seguro de que ustedes entienden,
pero también el técnico, dónde tomamos los materiales
y los colocamos en ciclos cerrados.
Los llamamos nutrición biológica y nutrición técnica.
La nutrición técnica será diez veces mayor a la nutrición biológica.
La nutrición biológica puede dar aprovisionar a 500 millones de humanos,
lo que significa que si todos lleváramos zapatos Birkenstocks y algodón,
el mundo se quedaría sin corcho y se secaría.
Así que necesitamos materiales en ciclos cerrados,
pero debemos analizarlos hasta las partes por millón
en relación al cáncer, problemas de nacimiento, efectos mutagénicos,
interrupción de nuestro sistema inmunológico, biodegradación, persistencia,
contenido de metales pesados, conocimiento de cómo se están fabricando,
su producción y así sucesivamente.
Nuestro primer producto fue un textil en el que hemos analizado 8.000 químicos
en la industria textil.
Utilizando filtros intelectuales, hemos eliminado 7.962
Nos hemos quedado con 38 químicos.
Hemos introducido en base de datos los 4000 químicos más utilzados
en la fabricación para uso humano, y publicaremos esta base de datos al público en seis semanas.
Para que los diseñadores alrededor del mundo puedan analizar sus productos
hasta las partes por millón en relación a la salud humana y ecológica.
(Apausos)
Hemos desarrollado un protocolo para que las compañías puedan enviar
estos mismos mensajes a través de toda su cadena de proveedores,
porque cuando preguntamos a la mayoría de las empresas con las que trabajamos -- de alrededor de un trillón de dólares
-- y dijimos, "¿De dónde vienen sus cosas?", dijeron, "Proveedores".
"¿Y adónde van?"
"Consumidores".
Así que necesitamos un poco de ayuda aquí.
Por tanto los nutrientes biológicos, los primeros tejidos --
el agua que salía fuera era lo suficientemente limpia como para beber.
Nutrientes técnicos -- esto es para Moquetas Shaw, moquetas infinitamente reutilizables.
Aquí está el nylon volviendo a la caprolactama y luego a la moqueta.
Nutrientes biotécnicos -- el Modelo U de la Compañía Ford,
un coche concepto - de cuna a cuna.
Zapatos Nike, dónde la parte de arriba es de poliester, infinitamente reciclable,
las suelas son biodegradables.
Lleva tus zapatos viejos dentro, y tus zapatos nuevos por fuera.
No hay línea de meta.
La idea aquí del coche es que algunos de los materiales
vuelvan para siempre a la industria, algunos de los materiales vayan de nuevo al suelo --
es todo movido por energía solar.
Aquí hay un edificio en el Oberlin College que hemos diseñado
que produce más energía de la que necesita para operar y purifica su propia agua.
Aquí un edificio para La Gap, dónde los antiguos pastos
de San Bruno, California, están en el techo.
Y este es nuestro proyecto para la Compañía Ford,
es la revitalización del río Rouge en Dearborn.
Esto es obviamente una foto a color.
Estas son nuestras herramientas. Así es como se lo vendimos a Ford.
Le hemos ahorrado a Ford 35 millones de dólares haciéndolo de esta manera, día uno,
que es el equivalente al Ford Taurus
a un cuatro por ciento de margen de un pedido de coches de 900 millones de dólares.
Aquí está. Es el techo verde más grande del mundo, 10 acres y medio.
Este es el techo, ahorrando dinero,
y estas son las primeras especies en llegar. Estos pájaros son chorlitejos colirrojos o chorlos gritones (Killdeer).
Tardaron cinco días en aparecer.
Y ahora tenemos trabajadores de 350 libras de peso
aprendiendo canciones de pájaros en internet.
Estamos desarrollando protocolos para ciudades --
este es el hogar de los nutrientes técnicos.
El país -- el hogar de la diversidad biológica. Y luego, unificándolos.
Y así, voy a terminar mostrándoles una nueva ciudad
que estamos diseñando para el gobierno chino.
Estamos haciendo doce ciudades para China ahora,
basándonos en el "cuna a cuna" como plantilla.
Nuestra misión es desarrollar protocolos para la vivienda
de 400 millones de personas en doce años.
Hicimos un estudio de masa y energía -- si usan un ladrillo,
ellos perderan sus suelos y quemarán todo su carbón.
Tendrán ciudades sin energía ni comida.
Firmamos un Acuerdo de Entendimiento --
aquí está la Señora Deng Lan, hija de Deng Xiaoping --
para que China adoptara el "de cuna a cuna".
Porque si se intoxican a sí mismos, siendo los productores de más bajo coste,
lo envían a la distribución de más bajo coste -- Wal-Mart --
y luego nosotros les enviamos todo nuestro dinero, lo que descubriremos es que
tenemos lo que, efectivamente, cuando yo era estudiante,
se llamaba, destrucción mútuamente compartida.
Ahora lo hacemos por moléculas. Estas son nuestras ciudades.
Estamos construyendo una nueva ciudad, cerca de esta ciudad; observen el paisaje.
Este es el lugar.
Normalmente no hacemos campos de hierba, pero éste está a punto de ser construído,
así que nos trajeron para interceder.
Este es su plan.
Es una plantilla tipo sello que ellos han colocado justo sobre ese paisaje.
Y nos trajeron y nos dijeron, "¿Ustedes qué harían?"
Esto es con lo que hubieran hecho, que es otra foto a color.
Así que este es el lugar actualmente, así es como se ve ahora,
y esta es nuestra propuesta.
(Aplausos)
Así que la manera en la que abordamos esto
es que estudiamos la hidrología muy cuidadosamente.
Estudiamos la biota, la antigua biota,
la agricultura y protocolos actuales.
Estudiamos los vientos y el sol para asegurarnos de que todos en la ciudad
tendrían aire fresco, agua limpia y luz solar directa
en cada uno de los apartamentos en algún momento del día.
Luego tomamos los parques y los diagramamos como infraestructura ecológica.
Colocamos las áreas de edificios.
Comenzamos a integrar el uso común y comercial
para que todas las personas tuvieran centros y lugares para estar.
El transporte es todo muy sencillo,
todos tienen movilidad en un lapso de cinco minutos a pie.
Tenemos una calle 24-horas, para que así siempre haya un lugar vivo.
Los sistemas de desperdicios están todos conectados.
Si tiran de la cadena de un retrete, sus heces irán a las plantas de tratamiento de aguas residuales,
que son vendidas como activos y no como pasivos.
Porque, ¿quién quiere la fábrica de fertilizantes que produce gas natural?
Las aguas son todas tomadas para la construcción de humedales para la restauración del hábitat.
Y luego produce gas natural, que vuelve a la ciudad
para proveer la energía necesaria para cocinar.
Entonces esto es -- estas son plantas para la producción de gas.
Y luego todo el abono se lleva de nuevo
a los techos de la ciudad, donde tenemos los cultivos,
porque lo que hemos hecho es subir la ciudad,
el paisaje, al aire para -- para recuperar el paisaje nativo
en los techos de los edificios.
La energía solar de todas las fábricas
y de toda la zona industrial con sus ligeros techos dan energía a la ciudad.
Y este es el concepto para toda la parte de arriba de la ciudad.
Hemos subido la tierra a los techos.
Los agricultores tienen pequeños puentes para pasar de un techo a otro.
Hemos habitado la ciudad con espacios de vida/trabajo en todas las plantas bajas.
Y así esta es la ciudad existente, y esta es la nueva ciudad.
(Aplausos)